So I've been talking about this for a couple
of days now, and I've been tweeting about
it for some time.
And I tweeted days ago, It's unlikely that
January 6th was the last riot or at least
the last attempted riot.
And indeed, ABC has now obtained an FBI bulletin
which is warning all 50 states and federal
law enforcement that armed protests are being
planned at all 50 state capitals.
It's expected to start as soon as days from
today and run at least through Inauguration
Day on January 20th.
Armed protests are being planned at all 50
state capitals.
And in Washington, D.C., the if you've been
following some of what's been happening on
the right wing social media platform parler,
you probably also know that at least the language
around going armed this time is significantly
scarier and more belligerent in terms of weapons
in D.C.
January 6th, there are anecdotally stories
and some pictures of what appear to be armed
insurrectionists, although it it is not clear
that that was an overwhelming issue on January
6th.
And of course, Washington, D.C., gun laws
are far stricter than the gun laws in many
of the states from which the insurrectionists
came on parler.
Increasingly, the language about going armed
to the next series of riots is significantly
more belligerent.
And to the extent that some of these riots,
rather than being in Washington, D.C., are
going to be at state capitals, it is likely
that many of these would be insurrectionists
will not only be armed at the future protest,
but they will be armed legally, OK.
The FBI has also received information about
a group that is calling for storming courthouses
as well as administrative buildings.
If Donald Trump is removed from office any
time prior to Inauguration Day or if Trump
is impeached by the House of Representatives
or storming once Joe Biden is sworn in, which
he will be on January 20th, regardless of
what else happens between now and then.
So there's there's a few thoughts about this.
Number one, the reality is that this isn't
we will do this only if Trump is impeached
or only if Trump is removed by the 25th Amendment.
The reality is that the this the likelihood
of this happening again is under any circumstance
in which Joe Biden becomes president.
So when I hear members of the Republican Party
saying we have to heal and move on, impeachment
would be divisive.
It's time to go.
Trump reduced the temperature with his ridiculous
one minute video last week or whatever.
They No.
One are clearly downplaying the current threat
level.
But most importantly, it doesn't matter what
the House or Senate do, the terrorists supporting
the Kuhnen garbage aren't going to change
their minds.
They're not going to stop if and when Joe
Biden becomes president and he's going to
it is likely that we are going to see more
of this.
And that's horrifying.
The only way that these people don't do it
is if somehow Trump is allowed to remain president.
That's the only condition that they will accept,
which is, of course, unacceptable to society.
It's incongruent with the law and it can't
be allowed to happen.
So that's the reality.
There will be right wing violence.
If Joe Biden is sworn in.
If Donald Trump is impeached, there will be
right wing violence.
If Donald Trump is removed via the 25th Amendment,
there will be right wing violence.
If Trump resigns because he will have been
forced to resign is the way that they will
see it.
So, unfortunately, if there's going to be
violence, there's going to be violence merely
because Donald Trump didn't get another four
years.
They're not rational.
They've tied their identity to Donald Trump.
And Trump is leaving and they're angry.
They are irrational.
Many of them feel lost.
They're not interested in governance or policy
or the rule of law.
And they've gone over the line and turned
to violence instead of respecting our institutions.
That that's it.
That's the full story.
Now we can pull in.
How much of it is economic anxiety, how much
of it is racism, how much is xenophobia, how
much of it is cognitive dissonance or ignorance?
What role does mental illness are in cell
culture play?
Great, but a line has been crossed where any
scenario in which Donald Trump doesn't get
another four years to some portion of these
people warrants violence.
And that's why the FBI is now worried about
what looks to be likely over the next week.
So let's all be safe.
Let's all be careful.
And we're going to continue following all
of this as well as what will the House of
Representatives and Senate do and Mike Pence
potentially about Donald Trump.
I believe he will be president all the way
to January 20th at noon.
We will have more about this on our Instagram
page.
Find us on Instagram at David Pakman show.
And you can also find me on Instagram at David
Pakman, The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.